aufgrund der freiwilligen meldung zum
auslandseinsatz werden die freiwilligen
durch das personalamt zu einer
zweitägigen eigens überprüfung und das
prüfzentrum ost nach wien stammersdorf
geladen
die eigens überprüfung umfasst die
feststellung der gesundheitlichen der
körperlichen und psychologischen
einigung für den bevorstehenden ordens
einsatz für die feststellung der
körperlichen leistungsfähigkeit sind in
2.400 meter warf und liegestütze
entsprechend der alterslimits für frauen
und männer zu erbringen
die umfassende medizinische überprüfung
erfolgt im heeresspital die überprüfung
der körperlichen leistungsfähigkeit und
die psychologische überprüfung erfolgt
im prüfzentrum ost des jahres
personalamtes 17 uhr also am späten
nachmittag beginnt psychologische
überprüfung im lehrsaal in der nacht
daneben geht es in die schutzräume im
schutzraum müssen sie dann die gesamte
nacht verbringen
in der früh kommen sie dann hinauf in
den lehrsaal und dann gibt es noch eine
wiederholungstat um diese
belastungsphase der der schutzraum
darstellt und zu sehen ist dieser mensch
wer noch von seiner konzentration soweit
fähig im bestimmte aufgaben zu erledigen
gleich weckte bei echter vorzunehmen es
kommt dann im anschluss zu nah am
schluss gesprächen mit psychologen
nach der positiv abgelegten eigens
überprüfung sind die freiwilligen
grundsätzlich für den auslandseinsatz
geeignet die einteilung und einberufung
für den einsatz erfolgt über das referat
dora 4 des personalamtes in
zusammenarbeit mit dem
streitkräfteführungskommando in graz